Carmichael: Landed on the ground.
Niko: [laughing] All right.
[Obie's claws clacking]
Sam: We went to Little Tokyo to do a quick little test, see how to hide Waldo.
S: He hid well, but every single person looked at us.
S: Specifically, every single person looked at Wren in a Waldo costume.
Wren: Yeah.
S: Everyone was coming up saying, "Ayy, Waldo! I found ya!"
S: Everyone.
W: No-one really understands just how well-known Waldo is.
W: Havin' issues.
W: For whatever reason, the top view was out of sync by, like, fifteen seconds.
S: Can you just manually sync the top one?
W: ...Yeah.
[Keyboard tap]
SFX: Muted whoosh
W:
W: Compared to everything that I've got in so far, this is actually really solid.
W: I'm behind this watermark.
S: It's pretty good.
W: Literally, you just lift up the entire rig, and just, like, spin it in a circle.
S: Wow, jeez.
W: Yeah, it's weird, yeah.
Jake: Waldo wears brown boots.
W: I honestly don't think the shoes are that big of a deal.
J: I don't understand why this is even a conversation.
S: Look - Wren's fine with the shoes. No-one's gonna say, "Hey, hold on."
S: "...That's not Waldo."
Brandon: Where's your [CENSORED] brown boots?
W: [laughing] I see what you did there.
B: No, Waldo has brown boots.
W: Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
S: Hold on.
W: All right.
S: Sucks for you.
W: We just locked it!
S: I know, 'cause the boots are on Jake's feet.
C: [laughing]
N: So whenever we go into video that requires us to do pretty, like, extreme guerrilla shooting,
N: ...especially when it's, like, interacting with the public as, like, FBI agents, I always get a little anxious.
N: Get a little worried that somebody's gonna think I'm, like, about to assault them or, like, blow up a bomb or something like that.
S: Cross the street, you walk through there and you walk up the square.
S: Then we're screwed.
SFX: Dramatic chord